okay for people joining this
live stream we are looking at some
incremental language development
for wolf language and a bunch of
features that we're hoping will make it
into the upcoming version 12.3
so first we have lexicographic order
um
yes so this example shows the main idea
that we look at the first elements
before looking at the lengths
right so i mean if you give it strings
will it do something
not this function that would be um
alphabetical
is that the right thing i mean most of
our functions
have i mean oh
is it obvious that it shouldn't do
something with strings it could do
something
with default settings but if you go to
alphabetic order you will see that it
has lots of settings
oh i know i understand that but i'm
saying do it with the default setting
um if we were to give
check that the both inputs are strings
yeah we could set it to alphabetic
order by default yes because right now
the default is order
right or what we could do is to
automatically convert to characters of
the string which gives a list and then
we proceed with those characters
that seems very sensible to me but how
do you
how do you sort so the sub ordering
inside lexicographic order
is order is that correct by default yes
with an optional third argument
exactly because numerical order for
example will be useful things in that
right we could have even lists of
strings and then we would have
lexicographic order with alphabetical
order
as an element order yes i understand
that makes sense
but i mean so so then okay so
a string would be treated here as if it
was a list of characters
at the top level i can do that
in other words if you have two strings
sure but if you have lists of strings i
don't think we want to do that no we
don't
okay well it just goes to the order
function but yeah yeah
fine and they can specify alphabetical
order if they want
okay we'll do okay
so something a bit problematic here is
that these functions work
on composite objects so the important
elements
are the elements of the lists so that's
why in the documentation
on the left if you go up a bit
you'll see that i use these lists a's
and b's to
to emphasize this
uh importance of the actual elements
right
it's difficult to explain if we're going
to compare a1 with b1
then the explanation gets very long
well you can certainly uh say it in the
in the um
details you can say
you know it's are considered in order
in um if
um
you know if the a sub i if the b sub i
are greater than the corresponding a sub
i
i think you should have something in the
notes that explains what this is
right the second note tries to do that
but it's
it's too short should be i think it
needs to give a little bit of the math
of it
right and it should say if it takes
things other than lists
because the usage looks like it only
takes lists yeah ended indeed
yeah we we agreed on that if it's an
association is it just the values
i think so i followed suit with what
other
um sort functions were doing with
association
basically called association sort after
giving the
order function creating and passing the
order function to it
well so in other words it sorts the
values in the association and it
pulls the keys along when those values
are in reordered is that correct
i assume so i don't actually know much
about
our sorting code for associations we
should check that
if it doesn't do that then let's worry
about it but if it does that i think
it's fine okay well
it should just return the associations
as they are
it's just telling you if they're ordered
or not i mean no problem
not knowing the case of sort yeah but
should i only be looking at the values
oh correct i was thinking about that but
when
when it sorts the values it drags their
keys along with them
right so i think those are two different
things that would be
lexicographic sort of an association
which is different from lexicographic
order of two associations
i agree right i was thinking about the
latter
right
okay so lexicographic order
should just look at values is that what
we're saying yes
but do the keys have to agree i think
the keys have to agree
right no i don't think so which is
completely independent of the keys
[Music]
i i would say that's more flexible
and then you can do a key sort
so i mean i guess you could do a key
sort with lex graphic order
as the sorting function right
okay sounds about right to me one thing
on the documentation
that you might consider jose is um
for electrographic order is for things
like and
and or we do have mentioned the short
circuiting property
so that would hold here as well what
does that mean
that as soon as you have a definitive
comparison you stop
yes because they're no longer equal yeah
that's probably worth mentioning
although it doesn't really have an
evaluation consequence which it does for
and and or
because hold functions sure yes
yeah that's true well here it could go
in details and options doesn't have to
be in the use
you know the um description
i mean okay all right let's
go to the trees so to speak
um sandra was commenting on our live
stream does he like the ij dutch example
good well glad we got it right
um okay
all right so here there are
multiple functions and i think the last
time we discussed about trees we had
some open questions
so here we um
we report on on what we decided mostly
the second point the tri-map point and
then there are a couple of
questions should tree automatically
canonicalize
so we agree that with one argument it
means children
yes so the question is whether for a
uniformity of results
we want to convert always to two
arguments
i don't know i would say probably yes
does ian have an opinion
i would like to canonicalize it okay
well i think that let's go with that
for now okay i mean unless it turns out
that we just have it's just full of
cruft
when you do operations on it okay i mean
you
will rarely see this okay tree map
right so the difficult question here was
whether to map on on the subtrees or the
payloads
and what we are proposing is that
because trimap has a level spec
specification we consider some sort of
notion of
extended level spec in which you
actually say
i want the data or the tree
and this can be used in various
functions if they have a
level spec oh yeah but normally a level
spec a list level spec is
a spam
yeah so if this is one two three levels
then this would be
the pair list one two three comma data
and you mean the
do you mean the data of all those levels
wait a minute an
ordinary level spec is either a single
level
or a span right or i mean it's
not a span it's either a number or a
list
okay but that list actually probably we
should also support spam because it
actually means a span
level zero through seven or something
right yes it may be that it is supported
but i
okay fine i can use it okay all right
but so that's the meaning of levels
normally
yes it's levels a through b and we
certainly could do that for trees have
levels a through b
correct correct yeah
okay but what we're saying here is
we are defining a
a way of map operating that says
look only at the data in those specified
levels or look only at the sub trees
at those specified levels right correct
yes and by default i mean which one did
we choose by default data data
yeah i think that's the most useful case
you know
right okay
so here we got a tree we got a function
f
a tree it's mapping over data
so and if i say down to level
if i say that it will map all the way
down the tree is that correct
what does it do by default that's
correct it maps
on the data from level 0 to infinity
okay which is like map all
yes okay if i wanted to map only on the
leaf nodes what do i do
do i say minus one here yes
okay so i would argue in the world of of
stringiness
that we might want this to work
i like that
and then if we did that
you know
or sub trees
that seems fairly civilized to be able
to those are the two cases
and the default is data but i mean that
that would be fine we could just say
data
there and these would be the all levels
versions of this
okay leaves obviously isn't an all
levels version because it's just the
leaves
although let me make a point that you
could want
leaves only down to level such and such
so i'm saying you could you could want
leaves
there uh i mean this is not something
that we have an ordinary map
right an ordinary map is there a way of
saying
i want the terminal nodes
yeah this is a case that we want here we
want terminal nodes
beyond level seven or something you see
what i'm saying
yes i think so
once we have this per notation in which
we have the standard level spec
comma something we can express those
things in the second argument
yeah i understand so in particular what
that's saying is
i want to look at okay
oh how does this work
i'm considering these bands within the
tree
oh how does that work well so leaves is
corresponding to certain levels
and subtrees and data are
referring to what portion of the thing
at particular levels that you're mapping
onto
yes that's correct but i'm what i'm
saying is that leaves
could also be treated differently that
is you could say i want the leaves but
only the ones that are below level three
for example
all right so now the question is what do
we do with the ordinary level specs here
and by the way leaves well leaves
there's only one thing that could
possibly mean it's it's data on the
leaves right there's no subtree there
could be a sub tree well then does it
have to be called leaf data
so leaves means is is an is equivalent
to minus one right
yes so then we could have list leaves
comma
data or leaves comma three
common subtrees subtrees yeah
right fair enough and the most common
case is just data
right do you need uh three elements in
the list
what's the third like from levels three
to five just leaves
so so that will be list list three five
commonly okay
but if you wanted to specify leaves and
data or leaves and subtree
in addition to that your toast
do two tree maps
because tree map i don't even see how
you could do that
yeah you'd have to take the tree
now normally with data the return value
from f
is just re-stuffed into the data slot
the return value for subtrees you know
the return value of f
with sub trees is presumably supposed to
be a tree because it's got to be
re-glued into the tree
it also gets stuffed into the data
really yes so what if i want to do
something where i rewrite
subtrees that's
going to require something like tree or
place
so but the analog in the case of
ordinary map it does replace the subtree
in the expression right
yes but with ordinary expressions we
don't have the distinction
of the subtree and the data no i
understand that
i understand that but i'm saying that it
does do the replacement of subtree
as opposed to just replacing at a
certain level
yes so it's a little different from this
okay but so now the question is
i mean my tendency would be to say that
it's nicer to have something
of the form levels
arrow data i don't like this list data
because it's saying
it's not like after you've done the
levels then you do the data
rather data is sort of a footnote or
something to the level specification
that's what i would prefer comments
illness
well being the last argument i mean if
there are options
i i i do like the the arrow i'm just a
bit
concerned with options it'll be fine i
mean that's what options pattern deals
with
it'll be fine we know what the options
are and they're certainly not lists of
numbers
right okay all right sound reasonable
and now i could imagine
that there are some other name things in
addition to leave subtrees
data
[Music]
i mean
i don't know but that's a good start at
least
and so levels arrow leaves
would give us presumably just the leafs
thus the leaf data it's a little bit
weird
at those levels
but leaves is equivalent to level minus
one yeah i know so maybe we don't have
that combined
maybe that's just the first argument
there
i think so okay i mean we can worry
about the thing where you want
the rim of the thing only down the level
such and such later
okay tree data structure
yes so the main question here is how to
convert from the tree object to the tree
data structure
and so we propose to having as we have
other three illustrations
reasonable it's amusing it's bizarre
um
given that there are several data
structure types
for trees this also offers the
opportunity to
specify which one indeed
i like it yeah data structure tree
i mean i don't know why normal doesn't
just convert to a tree object
it could we could do it too fine
um normal of these normal of the data
structure yes
they already have their own normal form
i see yes what what kind what do you
mean they're a normal
isn't the tree what the heck is it what
tree does currently if you ask normal is
it gives rules
well maybe it shouldn't maybe it should
give a tree
talk to the data structure people i
would suspect it should give a tree
but so we may not need a data structure
tree function
okay latest i see
although there may be some options in
the way it's converted so it might be
useful to have
and by symmetry given that you have
these powers of converters
let's have it and and one final question
do you agree that the
structure that we return from the tree
should be a copy not the original one
that
it would be mutable and therefore it
could
from data structure tree you're asking
what should data structure tree be yes i
think it should peel off an immutable
structure
a three data structure actually so from
the tree we extract a data structure
which internally was mutable and so we
will produce okay
oh absolutely absolutely it will be
completely
bonkers for these things to to you know
for that to reach into the innards of
the actual
tree which happens to be implemented
with a mutable data structure
right bonkers yeah okay good
okay all right
let's move on here okay
you know if you want to hear about my
you probably don't
i mean this is i realized that there's a
whole
you know that whole story of multi-way
systems
which we need to um uh
you know we are working towards having a
multi-way system
system function i don't know what
meetings we have set up for that yet
but that's something i want to do but
okay this is this is our conceptual
moment here
um
you know right now in our evaluator we
have the idea that there's a single
chain of evaluation
right it is it's bizarrely related to
this weird post that i wrote about
consciousness
which is all about threads of of
experience
and it's the same thing with our
evaluator the evaluator
just imagines you have an expression and
things happen to it things happen to it
and you get another expression
right in a multi-way system of the kind
that we think happens in
for example quantum mechanics etc etc
etc that isn't what happens instead you
get this whole big graph
of possible outcomes okay so my little
exercise was
imagine you were redesigning our
language
with the evaluator as sort of a quantum
evaluator
where it's just where everything is done
through a multi-way system
and there's not a single thread of of
evaluation
what would things look like did that did
that
idea make any sense
so what is offering the possibilities
because sometimes there is just one
thread you can follow
absolutely but but my point is this okay
so if i say resource function
of you know multi-way system
of something like you know a goes to
a b i don't know a goes to a
a i remember i've got some good examples
of this
b goes to bb goes to a or something i'm
not sure that's going to do anything
interesting
um
whatever just make up some random thing
here
um
oh my gosh what did that just do
i'm going crazy here what um
what did this just do oh oh this is some
bug in this version
did you see that
did you see that yeah i i saw it up here
later
right well okay let's go back to a
version where it doesn't
isn't buggy um
[Music]
what the heck this is 12 3
i'm running here so that
you should report this bug i got it yeah
it took a few screenshots
okay
i'm sorry this is taking too long to to
do but but um
ah wow weird
thing with this bug okay so so you
understand what this is doing roughly
right instead of an ordinary evaluation
you just go down
you know ordinary evaluation is always a
single path right so
for example replace versus replace list
replace
just replaces the first instance it's a
particular evaluation order
replace list would do the same thing
that this is doing
okay so the challenge is
you know this is like non-deterministic
computation
this is like our usual things like a
turing machine this is like all parts
for a non-deterministic turing machine
and the question is
what are the natural programming
primitives in that situation
okay that's my little exercise here
uh
anyway it's just a thing to think about
coming attraction let's say
okay sandra is asking can you also do a
map where one has access to both the
tree and the data like
map indexed or map thread
boy what is the analog map indexed for a
tree
well on the first thing if you have the
tree then you have the data
i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying so if you do the subtrees
case
you would have you could always extract
tree data
yeah it's strictly more powerful
fine um fine that's a good answer and i
think map index
is a like there's a sensible tree map
indexed where the second argument
would be the position that you're at
okay which we can consider introducing
um map thread
we have discussed that for example
something i'm
we were interested in is comparing two
trees
so a function that takes two trees and
heck yes i mean that's what we need for
for um uh expression diffs right
i mean we already have some expression
diff functions i think right
so yeah
so i think it it is possible if we have
two trees of the same structure
to the threading so it will be like like
the normal map thread which is a
function
that requires common structures
right to be able to compare but by the
way the tree def function
is really an important function
right how would we you know that's a
function where we want to annotate a
tree
i mean that is directly useful in
comparing two expressions right
yes yes but i believe we have some such
functions that have been built over the
years
but it will be good to understand that
better that's a really good use case for
the things to do with the trees
um yeah
we have thought about it as an
application but i'm i'm not sure it will
be ready in the first
round of functions i understand
i want to add it to my list of student
projects
uh hold on one second here
um
yeah i do remember by author tools i
think we had a
tool to compare notebooks yeah right
there's an expression line diff in the
function repository
okay all right
let's let's start taking a look at these
multiple axes plots
we know perfectly well this is going
into the system and that's a brett
story and he better be working on it i
mean that's access object was a
preliminary to that
make sense yep good
dynamic face grids behind
basically it makes it so that as you
spin around a 3d graphic
the the grids the faces all look nice
the whole time sounds right to me i mean
i don't know why we don't have that for
face grids automatic
right now that's a brett's story
right it's this implementation is
probably heavyweight but the idea is
there
yeah but so brett is the one who should
look at that
okay map cases i think we started
looking at this one last time
exactly yep i think it's a good idea
i mean i've certainly wanted that oops
i've certainly wanted that functionality
um
um sandra is asking is map thread
updated for ragged lists
do you know what's happened with that
map thread for rocket league
not yet so we have discussed various
generalizations of math
threat but none of them is implemented
yet
oh it's it's in the in the works okay
we'll be interested to see um uh
tally has been promising his new meta
theory of arrays
it'll be interesting to see what that
looks like
um okay map cases all right
like
will this new meta theory of arrays
decentralize the central dogma
of which of data set
association and list more
i don't know i think it's more
something i mean look tally developed
the whole data set query mechanism
and i think he's realized that it isn't
all it was cracked up to be and it's
kind of hard to understand and so i
think this is an effort
to to um uh develop a new way to do
those kinds of things
but we'll see okay map cases
what's that nothing
i mean i like this functionality what
what details does it have here
it's mostly copied from other similar
functions
evaluate cases
in order to evaluate inside held
expressions
okay that's a different issue okay so
the discussion last week
was that the so this will be implemented
more or less at first you do positions
and then you map at yes
so it's one of these functions which is
more or less an obvious combinations of
two existing functions
yes but it's still conceptually i think
it is a if it has the right name it's
conceptually useful
so that then for example map so would it
written a list of the cases or it would
return there no we just return
it does exactly what map does but
it look the reason this is useful okay
and it is really quite useful
is i i can imagine something which has
two levels
of of capability here a pattern
gate so to speak
so so i mean
okay so in this version there's pattern
and there's level spec
okay here's the thing i want to map onto
all list pairs that occur
inside an f
so in other words as you go down the
tree
i mean i've wanted this kind of thing
many many times that is
you've got a definition of mapping
and essentially what it is is it's a
wrapper around
f that says if f doesn't match this
pattern the function is identi
sorry if if hash doesn't match this
pattern f
is identity otherwise it's f right we
also have map if which is similar but
instead of a pattern it's a test
and they're conceptually similar to map
at except
instead of giving an index you're giving
a
pattern right and how does it try to
replace all
replace or replace pattern goes to f of
pattern
i think it look okay so well i mean it
works at multiple levels
right i i guess yeah well that
it is related but i would prefer to
think about a headdress
yeah something like um
um i mean okay look
this is the wrong name but apply if
matches
f comma pattern
or something like this
something that's the operator
that's the operator yes that's the
operator and then you put that in
because then you can put it in map you
can put it in
fold you can put it in all kinds of
things well no you can't put it in fold
you can put it in map
um
what will be a good name for this
uh and if it doesn't match it returns it
it becomes identity exactly
well match up light
it's almost a filter
match applied
yeah so it's like reverse supplied
how to apply matched applied apply if
no because it's got to be an applied
family
well i mean okay applied f but if would
we want a condition
oh no no i know that's the case right
that's the two cases
i mean it's applied f
but that's not actually an interesting
case applied if because
because that thing
no it is an interesting case that's
that's the condition case
and then it's applied applied match q
or applied matching
applied if is a nice name so that would
be a test
and an f i think or maybe the other way
around
f test
yeah that's more like because it's more
like than the confirmed setup
that's kind of nice actually
so both f and test would receive the
argument
that's correct test first test
runs if test works it applies f
otherwise it doesn't so for example
applied if
would be very commonly would be
something like
you know hash greater than zero
because that saves you from writing you
know if hash greater than zero hash
you know if hash less than zero hash
otherwise f of hash
which i write all the time
i see
okay so then the question is what is the
corresponding thing for matching
um applied on
where do i put these by the way you have
a folder called wfr functions
or the ild folder i think you've saved
in both places before
okay so what was the applied on
i don't like that uh
it's more like
but how do you give some sort of
conditional
applied match q is very weird applied f
is really kind of nice sounding
pattern up light that sounds wrong
because it's like reverse supplied
but not so to speak
um
well if it has to be similar to applied
if it could be applied if much
but it's always rewards oh you have it
there yeah
applied matched
and was not much applied to follow
reverse apply an operator applied
why would that make sense for operator
applied i mean why is that like
it's actually not totally silly
okay so match applied would have the
thing
about pattern
so remind me that operator applied
what we're doing is we're saying f if f
is operator applied
no it's f of x is operator applied to y
right
match replied isn't hopeless
applied if and match applied
let's investigate those more i i kind of
like those i think they're useful
you know like functional programming
constructs
i wish the order of the words wasn't
different between the two
i wish it wasn't different as well
test applied instead of applied if
i like that
although i really like applied if so
would be great to see
there's a way to get the matching one
that way round
well proven preliminarily test applied
and match applied
see we've got confirm let's see we've
got confirmed by
which is a test
apply on match
on matching
well i think it's applied on matching
and then that gets a little weird
suggests some kind of temporal structure
all right let's push forward these are
interesting match applied test applied
with applied if being in second place
there
image color replace
do we have anybody from image processing
here
what's that no i don't think so okay
then we can't discuss this without them
this is basically a green screen
function
it's up to them we need we need them in
one of these meetings okay
yep pretty form
we already said send that to
brenton right yep yep okay
slice
how many different functions do we need
here i mean we've already had extract
why isn't this just an operator why
isn't extract got an operator form like
this
it already has extract of something
so why is this any different from that
well extract and part are slightly
different i'm not supporting that we
have a
an operator form for plus for part but
the fact that we have one for extract is
is
is not enough because position specs and
part specs are different
right but this is saving the fact that
part with one argument because part is
their args
the part with one argument is the
non-part
so to speak this is an attempt to work
around that issue
right but i mean these could support
also multi
uh argument part specs
so what's the point of that i mean yeah
i understand that it could have
i mean that even if part of x was not
x this would still be more powerful
but but again i i i don't think we need
yeah i don't think this is a good thing
right now right we have
nice ways of accessing part with double
bracket etc
yes okay
to regex
[Music]
right if this works well it'd be great
i mean really what this is you know
we've got this function regular
expression right
wait a minute this is displaying this in
some funky
form right as a regex
oh as a string it's converting between
wolfram string
patterns no i understand i understand
that but we have a representation for
ray x's
which is regular expression of blah
right it's a rapper so to me
this is like uh you know the story will
be this is to regular expression
and it would take in you know
whatever it is uh dot dot for example
and turn that into regular expression
of a star or whatever it is
sure it should have the wrapper on the
output
yeah but what about the other way around
from a regular expression
do we have one of those danny i don't
remember
i mean it's not always possible but it's
usually possible i think it is always
possible in some form
but slash semis and things
well i would say that i don't consider
this super high priority but i think it
is nice
to have
[Music]
i mean we do need one thing we do need
and it's something that we should
develop
and actually it's something we could
develop initially as a data structure
is um finance automata
okay we've had various packages for that
i think we need to
you know actually finish the job and
have those
and the reason they're non-trivial like
trees have
a little bit of extra plumage beyond
what's
on graphs for finite automata you know
the edges get labeled with things
and they're you know do you get what i'm
saying
you know what we should we should add
that to sushma's project list
i think it's something we should
consider doing
you add too many things to that list and
it becomes infinite automata
yes uh
sander is commenting that in map cases
you could have a side effect
actually i don't think his example is
correct but i mean in general
with applied if
well yes you could have a nasty
sort of side effect-y criterion there
yeah for sure that's up to you
okay cell information
what was the decision on to regular
expression
i'm wondering i would say yes but low
priority
okay is the name okay should it be to
regex
string to read no no no no because it
because it's
if we're going to return a regular
expression object then
the name is fine i think the name is
fine and i think we also need from
regular expression
now that in general can be done or no
yes i think it can be done i mean it
might require slash semicolon conditions
okay this is not high priority
i think it's a nice to have
and i wonder in a case like this whether
we shouldn't annotate somehow the the
function repository or at least
um so that
you know somebody can know that this is
something that will be nice to
change in the function repository now
it's no it's
not a sensible idea never mind okay
cell information
so what is the difference between this
and options of evaluation cell
i think this has more stuff in it
okay so there's a bunch of stuffing so
to speak options
evaluation cell okay i
am confused here
so these are non-overlapping collection
of things i don't understand this
right i'm surprised that the options
aren't
in the cell information one but yeah i
mean you wouldn't expect style to be in
options right it's the second argument
right but the real question that i have
is why should why is information not
working on a valuation cell
yeah it seems like the place to put this
yes
i think this is a useful thing but i'd
like to understand what some of these
things actually are
by the way i also would like to comment
that i think cell change times
should become date objects
i think these are kind of bonkers
are making sense
yeah yes i mean that that's uh can you
take that to the front end group maybe
yeah it's a front-end question yeah at
least they should appear that way even
if they're stored different
right
um
okay okay so i think the answer to this
is yes we're interested
but how does this relate to information
and what are all these properties here
okay from
character name
this seems like a useful function
although to what extent is it similar to
entity
it seems useful to me yeah there are
some cases that he
that where this is uniquely useful in
properties and relations i don't know if
they're
things that are missing in yeah
it's not the same as just wrapping it in
slash bracket
bracket yeah
no this is a good idea this is a good
idea we should have this
yeah so this goes along with from
character code right
yeah let me be on the same guy page
is a good idea okay
i vaguely heard of this thing seems
useful to me i don't see any reason not
to have this
um one thing is that
there is i think this ongoing
linear algebra overhaul so it
probably could be done in as part of
that hole
yeah it sounds right to me yeah i don't
mind implementing it it's it's my code
but
i i don't want to go behind devendra on
that yeah okay fine just just coordinate
with him i mean this is not a high
priority just coordinate with him okay
has definitions q
i mean this kind of is obviously useful
but really it's some kind of down value
cue
isn't this just doing the same thing
that value q does now
except it also checks for messages
i'm not sure how it's implemented i know
it's it's looking for
values down values own values messages
everything
okay so so the question is is it
equivalent to value q if yes
then we don't need it if no then we have
to understand
so the default by the way this better
have a c also to value cue here
should get changed the default method
for value queue is
symbol definitions present which checks
for down values on values etc so that
seems the same
but the thing value queue does not check
that messages are defined
well maybe it should
maybe it should why don't you look at
that
see how you know see what whether
there's a meaningful difference here
yeah this is useful this is useful we've
i have to say i think we need more
i mean the color maps we have it's kind
of random you use you know some jolly
color map
i think we need to and this is a
discussion with brett for example
we need to come back and um
[Music]
you know i i've wanted things like this
all the time
i don't think this is quite the right
name but this is a discussion we should
have
makes sense but it needs brett
what the heck is this
uh is this the equivalent of x equals
hash
yes we don't need this
it's popular people like it but i know
that there are also people who hate it
and there's at least two of them in this
major
go ahead we now have applied to
yes but that's different i see you're
arguing
apply to suggest we might want set two
no the other way around that apply to is
more general than set two
no it isn't this is equivalent to x this
is a known value set up
am i confused here no i think i'm just
thinking of
applied to with identity or something
like that
okay so apply to
has the thing you're applying to
what does it have it has f and x right
but which way round is it x comma f
right
yes okay so what you're saying is
this is x equals f of
whatever this thing is here
yes no i i'm i'm withdrawing that i
think i was confused
no i don't think apply to is an operator
like that it says x equals f of x
oh okay it's like an increment sort of
thing
yeah which is then completely different
from set to in this setup
i think so yeah yeah i was confused okay
i think this is a no
the name of this is wrong if it came
through today it wouldn't get this name
well unless that's some trade name
effectively for that
there should be a second word on it
though right it should be regression
or something yeah filter there should be
a second word on it
yes that should be there's a neural
networks i think or somewhere else
well i agree having this as a filter
seems useful
however yeah the function is useful the
name in the function repository is
unfortunate yeah that said it's probably
a very nice
thing to have so let's have it lost
filter
that goes to shoddy's group or
yes okay
that's interesting i mean i don't know
what the
this is the recursive association
because the just
association would do this right it goes
deep
could association have a second argument
that would do that
or is that crazy i think association is
varughs
it is
i would say not not not exciting right
now
bring it back again another time i'm not
i'm not convinced about that one
totives sounds like some kind of um
animistic belief system totatives
oh total tips okay well it's like totem
poles or something i don't know
how it's a good pride well that's
interesting it seems useful
i i mean i've certainly wanted that
a bunch of times i just never heard the
name total tips
if that name is common i i say yes
okay i mean it it reminds me of totient
right
but it's presumably it's the it's the
it's the stuff of which a totient is
made
tomatoes potatoes and chives
and total tips okay um we need to wrap
up here in a moment
um
oh boy this is the analog of delete
duplicates isn't it
yeah of a sort yes
i'm not um
so probably there is a whole family here
of possible functions
yes that do well the set i mean unsorted
unsorted intersection is another one
right right
that's what i mean that you could have
an inserted version of every
set theoretical function i think we may
have some of those coded in
examples in the documentation
but look unsorted union we don't have we
have delete duplicates which is the
one-legged union
without reordering i think we should
consider unsorted unionized
complement unsorted i think it's i i
know personally delete duplicates of
flatten
is an idiom i use all over
yes i think we should consider unsorted
union complement intersection
yeah having efficient versions of these
functions would be very useful
we should we should consider it
yeah various people are pointing out
that totatives are
appear in various places in math world
and so on
okay all right we should probably wrap
up here lots of exciting things to look
at another time
it's not some uh
boy there's a lot of stuff here well
good
i think this is all just february 2019.
what do you mean really yes but that was
possibly the most prolific that was the
biggest it was the biggest month yet
we got good stuff going into the
function repository very non-trivial and
interesting stuff
the um you know the one thing i yeah
anyway okay we should wrap up for now
uh those are following live streams we
have two more and one of the next one
i'm doing
is a q a about history of science and
technology that's a recreational one for
me
so for those interested see you there
otherwise and i think we have another
one
in a few hours that's a language
completeness and consistency
somebody has taken notes about a where
we stopped and b
what the dispositions are of the
functions we went over today
yep i got just about everything thank
you very much
okay